The ending of The Invisible Man doesn't unfold
exactly how you expect, but that's only fitting
for Leigh Whannell's twisty horror-thriller.
The Invisible Man's ending isn't a straightforward
one, but it's the right one for the movie.
Here's how it goes down. Spoilers ahead!
The Invisible Man's final showdown seems simple.
Cecilia visits Adrian's house for a meal.
When Adrian refuses to apologize, Cecilia
leaves to freshen up. While she's gone, Adrian
lifts a knife seemingly against his will,
even though he's alone in the room and slits
his own throat. Cecilia returns just in time
to watch him die.
Everything Cecilia does in this scene is set
up earlier in the movie. The security cameras
that Adrian used to spy on Cecilia are now
the key to proving his "suicide," and throughout
the film Adrian's weapon of choice is a knife.
It's only fitting that his story ends with
one.
And then, of course, there's the second invisibility
suit that Cecilia dons, the one she found
while snooping around Adrian's mansion. That's
why Adrian's comeuppance is so satisfying:
In the final scene, Cecilia is using all of
Adrian's tricks against him. She even sends
Adrian to the grave with his own catchphrase.
"Surprise"
During the meal, Adrian pleads for forgiveness,
saying that he's sorry. Is he, though? Because
everything that Adrian does in this scene
screams that he hasn't changed at all. He's
still choosing Cecilia's meals for her, and
still trying to gaslight her. He blames Cecilia
for her own trauma, deflecting responsibility
and painting himself as the real victim.
This is all textbook behavior for an abuser,
and it's not any different than what Adrian
was doing while he was in the invisibility
suit. From all indications, Adrian hasn't
learned a thing. Thankfully, Cecilia doesn't
fall for it. She's moved beyond Adrian, and
she's no longer looking back.
The Invisible Man is framed like an empowerment
story. At the beginning of the movie, Cecilia
lives in fear of Adrian. Even after she escapes,
she's so traumatized that she can't even leave
the house. Adrian's death gives her solace,
but it's only once the Invisible Man begins
attacking that Cecilia finally musters the
courage, resolve, and confidence that she
needs to fight back. By the end of the movie,
Cecilia and Adrian have switched places. Cecilia
is now the hunter. Adrian is her prey.
That's one way to look at it, anyway. Another
is that, despite losing his life, Adrian won.
The Cecilia we met near the beginning of the
film the kind, compassionate woman is gone.
Her sister is dead. She has blood on her hands.
Her emotions have been replaced by a calm,
cool detachedness.
It goes even further than that, though. As
we've seen, Cecilia has learned how to use
all of Adrian's tricks, including how to get
away with murder. That's not to say that she's
the same as Adrian that dude is still much,
much worse but Adrian obviously broke Cecilia,
and it's not clear if she'll ever truly recover.
As a thriller, The Invisible Man is taut and
well-paced, but as a result it doesn't always
take the time to explain everything. Most
notably, Cecilia's big $5 million payout a
key piece of Adrian's plan to torment Cecilia,
and one of the key drivers of the plot isn't
mentioned in the last bit of the movie. Presumably,
Adrian's will still applies the second time
he dies, but we'll never know for sure if
Sydney ends up with enough cash to go to her
dream college.
Same goes for how Adrian faked his death the
first time presumably, the deception was convincing
enough to fool the police. Cecilia's revenge
doesn't quite hold up if you think about it,
either. The authorities know that Cecilia
and Adrian have been mixed up with an invisibility
suit, which was used to commit a violent crime.
Even with the seemingly definitive camera
footage and James' testimony, there's going
to be a pretty thorough investigation, and
Cecilia is sure to be a prime suspect.
Maybe that's why Cecilia takes off after making
the 911 call. Still, while none of these loose
threads really matter as far as The Invisible
Man's main story are concerned, they're proof
that the movie's tidy ending isn't quite as
slick as it seems.
Leigh Whannell's The Invisible Man doesn't
need a sequel. By the end, Cecilia and Adrian's
stories are complete. But this is Hollywood,
and if The Invisible Man is a hit, it's hard
to imagine that Sony and Blumhouse won't try
to build a franchise out of it.
"This movie comes along catering for people
who are just walking in there for the first
time. And the horror fans are like, 'I know
all this stuff.'"
Clearly, Whannell knows how it goes. In an
interview we had with Whannell, he told us
that the only Invisible Man material he consumed
before writing the 2020 reboot was H. G. Wells'
original novel and James Whale's 1933 feature
film. He basically ignored all the sequels,
which is probably for the best.
"Ah-choo!" "Gesundhe--who's there?"
None of those sequels really follow the plot
established in 2020's The Invisible Man, but
the idea of someone else getting their hands
on the invisibility technology and embarking
on a whole new adventure could be the way
forward. Definitely don't expect a straight-up
remake of The Invisible Woman, even though
that seems like the most obvious direction
to go. The 1940 feature is actually a screwball
comedy in which a former model uses invisibility
to stop some idiot gangsters. A suitable follow-up
to a moody, paranoid thriller it certainly
ain't.
Of course, there's already an Invisible Woman
feature film in development at Universal,
but don't be fooled. This isn't a second act
for Elisabeth Moss' Cecilia Kass. It's an
entirely different project.
The project comes from Elizabeth Banks, who's
set to direct and star in a more traditional
Invisible Woman remake for Universal. The
Hollywood Reporter says the movie is like,
quote, "Thelma & Louise meets American Psycho."
Banks' film is another attempt by Universal
to revitalize its classic horror properties
after Tom Cruise's The Mummy sunk the studio's
planned Dark Universe franchise right out
of the gate. It's not a follow-up to Whannell's
movie but considering how good The Invisible
Man turned out to be with its smart, sparse
approach to horror, hopefully it follows his
lead.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't miss
a single one.